[Musik]
sebastian deckt auf das klebrige zusätze
in unserer dosensuppe stecken aber gar
nicht drauf stehen müssen und die alge
verschwindet von der zutatenliste was
für ein cooler trick er zeigt die
industrie zahlreiche zusätze für schweiz
wann hatten sie das letzte mal zu hause
so ein hühner nudel eintopf aus der dose
ehrlich und wie wir schon sehen
die ganze anlage wandert auf den boden
und wenn man das jetzt über die
abfüllanlage laufen lassen würden werden
in den ersten drei dosen alles voll mit
der einlage und die letzten hätten nur
grün
damit das nicht passiert hat die
lebensmittelindustrie technologische
hilfsstoffe damit alles schön in der
schwebe bleibt und wir die gleichen
anteile in jeder dose finden da wollen
wir mal dafür sorgen dass die einlage
jetzt in der mitte anfängt zu fliegen
alginat alginat ist ein bindemittel das
aus algen hergestellt wird in der
lebensmittelindustrie erfreut es sich
steigender beliebtheit
die getrockneten algen werden einfach
mit kaltem wasser angerührt
[Musik]
kleister für den menschlichen körper ist
alginat ungefährlich nur bei sehr hoher
dosierung kann es zu
verdauungsbeschwerden führen
das alginat soll in den nächsten minuten
die festen bestandteile der suppe in der
schwebe halten
april hilfen so nennt die industrie
diese speziellen hilfsstoffe damit immer
die gleiche menge einlage in die
dosensuppe kommt
ich kann zaubern die nudeln schweben das
hühnchen spät ich kann apfel das alginat
macht die suppe für das abfüllen
zähflüssig rein rechtlich gilt es als
technischer hilfsstoff weil alginat nur
wegen der maschinellen abfüllung
benötigt wird auf dosensuppen steht aber
praktisch nie alge auf der zutatenliste
wie kann das sein bei den hosen müsste
ich auf die zutatenliste plus alge
schreiben gebe sie den topf und die alge
verschwindet von der zutatenliste was
für ein cooler trick auch in der fabrik
werden die dosen noch einmal gekocht
durch die wärme verändert sich das
alginat in der suppe beim erhitzen
verliert es die fähigkeit wasser sehr
flüssig zu machen
das alginat ist in der fertigen suppe
aber immer noch enthalten doch weil es
keine funktion mehr erfüllt müssen
hersteller ist nicht als zutat angeben
[Musik]
suppe ist fertig denn das gesetz sagt
nur wenn ein hilfsstoff am ende aussehen
geschmack oder konsistenz der fertigen
suppe verändert muss er auf der
verpackung genannt werden
[Musik]
die suppe ist in der fertigen dose
genauso flüssig wie sie sein soll
alge ist drin steht aber nicht drauf so
sind die gesetze für die
lebensmittelindustrie funktioniert
verbraucherschützer beklagen seit jahren
dass der einsatz von hilfsstoffen ein
schlupfloch ist es ermöglicht
herstellern allzu oft unbeliebte zutaten
zu verschweigen
dabei können hilfsstoffe durchaus
auswirkungen auf die gesundheit haben
hilfsstoffe werden meistens alleine
getestet aber eben nicht im verbund mit
anderen sachen im lebensmittel und dass
das problem wir wissen eigentlich gar
nicht so genau was dieser ganze cocktail
dann hinterher mit uns anstellt selbst
bei aromatisiertes wasser kommen bei
vielen herstellern hilfsstoffe zum
einsatz
auch wenn nur wasser zucker und
natürliches aroma auf der verpackung
steht sebastian nägel deckt auf was
sonst noch drin steckt ihr leben hallo
hallo ich bin der sebastian und du
mansour frau karin derks frau karin
werks karin derks seinem befreundet ist
meine mutter
[Musik]
sebastian lege hat dreimal wasser mit
geschmack mitgebracht bei markenprodukte
einmal von gerolsteiner einmal von
volvic und eins vom discounter
jetzt wird es richtig spannend in einem
von den dreien wird zur abfüllung
desinfektionsmittel dazu gegeben corona
oder immer schon schon immer diese
infektion mittel die medica bonath ist
ein ziemlich starkes desinfektionsmittel
sein einsatz ist in der
getränkeindustrie weit verbreitet bei
der abfüllung wird eine kleine menge des
mittels mit in die flasche gespritzt
dadurch werden sämtliche keime abgetötet
kurz darauf zerfällt das die methyl die
karbonat von selbst in methanol und
kohlensäure zwei natürlichen
bestandteilen von mineralwasser
also ist das quasi wie ein
konservierungsstoff richtig richtig wäre
hätte ich nie im leben gedacht
aber wer verwendet ist markenhersteller
oder discounter die tester sollen ein
wasser trinken
desinfektionsmittel bitte schön
geschockt
unsere tester greifen zur sicherheit
lieber zu den teuren marken
und ich kann schon ganz schön dass apfel
auch romane das lecker das ist nicht gut
ist das lecker ist eben genau das
gewählt was wir desinfektionsmittel
abgefüllt wurde
desinfektionsmittel im trinkwasser weil
es beim abfüllen zerfällt muss es nicht
auf der zutatenliste angegeben werden
das würde ich dann nicht klüger keiner
weiß bescheid
es bleibt jetzt leider im stall stehen
ja das schon kassen also stimmt schon
heftig wir haben immer mal ein paar
kisten nach von zu hause oder jetzt
sollen das desinfektionsmittel mit
gerolsteiner argumentiert dass das
mittel im verkauften wasser nicht mehr
enthalten sei doch stimmt das wirklich
wir schicken zehn wasser proben ins
labor
bei gerolsteiner lässt sich tatsächlich
kein desinfektionsmittel nachweisen
dafür stellen wir beim wasser von fürst
bismarck spuren des mittels fest
unterhalb der grenzwerte zwar aber
immerhin auch aus diesem grund sehen
verbraucherschützer den einsatz von
hilfsstoffen kritischen viele substanzen
die aus technischen gründen in unseren
lebensmitteln landen sind für sich
genommen hochgiftig sie dürfen auf
keinen fall im endprodukt enthalten
seien kein problem solange die
produktion einwandfrei funktioniert zum
glück gibt es einige hersteller die
darauf verzichten
das sollten eigentlich alle tun denn es
scheint ohne zu funktionieren
und da dieser verarbeitungs hilfsstoff
ein sicherheitsrisiko sein kann sollten
ihn eigentlich alle hersteller aus ihren
produkten verbannen
doch der verzicht fällt schwer
hilfsstoffe machen industrielle
produktionsverfahren oft überhaupt erst
möglich
hunderte technologische hilfsstoffe sind
zugelassen
verbraucher erfahren von ihrem einsatz
aber nichts
sie müssen sich auf die sorgfalt der
hersteller verlassen und können
potenziell schädliche stoffe beim
einkauf nicht meiden
[Musik]
denkt ihr die hilfsstoffe sollten
angegeben werden sagt es uns in den
kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonnier zdf besser
esser und schaut in den nächsten zwei
clips